this country was built on slavery which
means slaves built this country till
this land from sea to Sea to Sea first
there was rice tobacco sugarcane see
when they did his thing and Captain
became and we weren't soldiers four
million strong fighting for America's
freedoms even though we remained America
slave bill says country
we the descendants of slaves in America
have earned reparations for their
suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged bruh
I'm sorry this is like oh my God child
programming to the max who thought it
who says it's a good idea to instill
children with anger and hatred over
things that happened in the past even if
it happened to their direct descendants
you know we all have things that happen
to our descendants and you know this
this I've had enough okay I've had
enough because Barack Obama Barack went
into office yeah and everybody thought
oh this is it we're gonna have a black
president all the black people
everything the streets are going to be
paid with gold and everything's gonna be
awesome and all he did there was this
little these Embers of racism left over
in America when he came out onto the
scene and he stoked them and he threw
oxygen in him and then he threw some
gasoline on him and he turned them into
a blazing fire again I lived here I know
yeah there was some problems nothing
like there is now he made it worse he
promised these people the world gave
them nothing nobody's better off and
they got rug pulled by him but worse is
that then Joe Biden his fight his
useless vice president comes along runs
for president yeah and they bought it
again they bought the same [__]
narrative again what are any of these
people doing to improve lives for the
black community overall nothing they're
not doing jack for the black community
you know you got people who want to give
school choice so that you know people in
poor communities can get out and go and
CR and go to a better school use a
voucher from the government to go get a
better school instead of being stuck in
the bottom of the barrel Community
School imagine if all this anger was
funneled into education and improving a
community that would make a difference
this is a bunch of horsesh and you just
create another generation of angry kids
and it's a shame and shame on everybody
who participated in this the writers the
actors the director the producer anybody
who airs this nonsense shame on them
shame on them for creating more division
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of people died to
free the slaves this is so one-sided and
angry I mean oh and slaves built this
country no you built you built a lot of
it you built the South but you didn't
build all of it I mean and you don't
have the market cornered on human
suffering enough it's over move on
because because putting your emotional
[__] on little kids is emotional
abuse a child should be able to look at
their neighbor and their kid and their
fellow classmates and find common ground
and be friends yeah not look at them and
think you're holding me down you know
like who are you holding down your
ancestors weren't even here I know they
arrived here 100 years ago yeah and you
got to pay for some [__] that they
didn't do we ain't having it it's over
stop with the division teach your
children to be kind tolerant loving and
look be on skin color because this is
not solving anything not only
40 acres and a mule we'll take the 40
acres so when I was growing up we did
learn about all the black inventors yeah
now now you just learned that um you're
oppressed yeah like we learned about we
learned so many positive things about
black people growing up you know it's
part of our education and it was
wonderful like we were just oh look at
these wonderful people look at these
wonderful women wonderful men they they
were great and they contributed yeah you
know what's interesting too is that
they'll go and they'll try to make like
historically White characters black
rather than just making new movies about
black stories that have never been told
before like there's plenty of those and
they do that too but yeah they're
they're just they're going I'm sorry
you're going about this all the wrong
way anger and division is not going to
solve your problems it doesn't endear me
to I'm not endeared to this cause at all
when you're screaming in my face about
some [__] I had nothing to do with sorry
and I don't tell me I have white
privilege please
no I'm done it's it's annoying I'm sick
of it look what they're doing to
Children the children need to see this
Jesus Jesus we still watch Sesame Street
and everybody played with each other
there was a blackhead a white kid a
Chinese kid a Spanish kid and everybody
was like let's play let's learn how to
count yeah let's talk to the little
green thing in the garbage can it was
fun that was childhood I know it's all
purposeful
we're partnering up with a Navy SEAL
friend of ours Tom Shea toast a 21 day
virtual event that you guys can join
with us Tom is going to teach you how to
listen to your mind in a new way and how
to control it so that you can have the
discipline you need to build the life
you want so I've seen this process done
for 30 years when you make it through
you will be a different human being the
process is simple but not easy because
of the war that's inside of us that few
people have been taught to fight
overcoming your excuses so if you're
interested in becoming a reformed human
an absolute animal go to tomshay.com and
use Sunny fast50 for 50 off of this
program you will not regret it you will
be a changed person at the end of it do
not miss this
than Plantation air to the northern
Bankers to the New England ship owner
the founding father
current Senators the Illuminati the New
World Order of slaves built this country
we had Tubman Turner Frederick B didn't
they say Lincoln free the slave but
slaves were men and women and only we
can free ourselves emancipation is not
Freedom so now we're going to [__] on
Abe Lincoln yeah what like let's just
shoot on Abe Lincoln now yeah you
back then did not free themselves
unfortunately yes if you look at the
numbers in in States I should bust out
my I have an almanac from
um 1856 I believe it is a few years
before the Civil War began and uh you
look at the numbers there were so many
more black people in each state in the
southern states than there were white
people but they were so mind controlled
and they were convinced that if they
stepped off the plantation they would
immediately be killed and they would be
hunted down so like and they were beaten
and starved and uneducated and not
allowed to have education so control
tactics it was disgraceful what what
went on with them yes given if they were
given resources yeah they absolutely
could have you know overcome and freed
themselves but why do we gotta [__] on a
blanket that man fought for decades for
this for decades
[Music]
but slaves were men and women and only
we can free us that's right you can free
your mind now from all this [__]
whenever you're ready it's funny that
they're making like the current racist
racism um protests and stuff synonymous
with slavery when it's like not even
close to the same thing at all it's the
current protests are just nonsense look
at this love
love peaceful about this about this
video about this video there's nothing
loving or peaceful this is stressful and
they'll be like yeah well we want you to
feel stressed because you need to
understand the problem no I want you to
go back to your community and teach your
children literature and math and science
so they can get out of generational
poverty and get into generational
stability and Financial Freedom that's
what I want for you to do but teaching
your children to just walk around
screaming what are you doing what do you
what you think that's progress what are
you doing come on get out get it doesn't
matter what you want yeah what is the
matter with these people
irrigation redlining Public Schools
feeding private prisons all over the
amount I've heard about redlining is
actually crazy they they wouldn't stop
talking about what is redlining tell me
because uh I feel like I've heard of it
but refresh my memory so I don't
completely butcher it I mean racial
discrimination of any kind in housing
but it comes through government maps
that outline areas oh yeah I don't know
if that's true might be well was a thing
but then they still they act like that
going on whatever decades ago is the
reason people are still broke and it's
like yeah I'm sure it has some effect
but if you taught people to have some
self-accountability and you know get off
their ass you know work hard anyone
would get out of that situation what do
we talk about all the time what quit
complaining and start fixing that's it
there's no complaining period no
complaining allowed do not complain
about your station in life stand up
become a better human being every single
day teach your children to do the same
help your community to do the same and
it will get better but if you just want
to sit and scream like a toddler enough
no no no done being yelled at just
because I'm white done leading private
prisons where we
wear weeds again as we say
we save this bill on Siri with me slaves
built this country and we demand our 40
acres and a mule you can keep them
you'll keep the 40.
you already have your freedom yeah what
are you doing with it you're screaming
[Applause]
oh the pride oh the pride if I saw my
son get up on a stage and scream at
people and be and put on this angry
victimhood display I would be mortified
and they're all and this is what they're
showing little kids this is okay could
you imagine yeah no I know it's it's
crazy you know it's it's like
programming at its in its purest form
right here remember I remember when I
was little and you know you told me
SpongeBob would melt my brain and you
know I would watch other TV shows and
not think too deep into it because
they're just kids shows they're just
simple kids jokes and here they are with
this [__] and then transgender stuff the
[__] you guys doing 150 years ago people
were slaves and you're still paying you
know and you're still held down and
somebody's got their you know their foot
on your neck like enough already spend
that messaging telling a kid that
they're smart that they're lovable that
they can do anything that they can you
know it's interesting because like you
don't see like Jewish people having all
this [__] non-stop like we're the Jews
you know we talk about redlining they
were literally kicked out of their homes
without any of their belongings and
shoved into a ghetto and that was only
like not even 100 years ago ghetto the
crazy part 80 years ago you really don't
hear about that then shoved on trains to
be exterminated six million of them
recently yeah and there's none of that
and that's it's all intentional I'm
telling you the people who run the world
want black people to think a certain way
and stay the way they are they
understand that you're not going to do
that with your own people because you
know they run the world and they're not
going to do that same thing to the
Jewish people they're smarter than that
it's just so sad and I'm not saying
there's there's no justification for
anger but take your anger and make
yourself and your community better buy
it you know really like I said go get an
education really really fight to build
something solid for your family and your
future because yes to bring up the Jews
that's what they did they came out and
they were like you killed all my family
I'm gonna have so many babies now that's
what they did some of them came out and
like women who survived were like I'm
gonna go find a husband and have eight
ten kids because I'm gonna repopulate
this the Earth with my children and you
have black people fighting for rights to
more abortions yeah it's like they're
killing their own killing their own off
like you could be reproducing now you
can't even talk about taking over you
could be you know taken every
opportunity that is given to you in this
country in for a free education and
making the most of it or you can just
scream in the streets and and ask for a
reparations check that's coming from
where where's this money coming from get
out of here yeah that's that's insane
keep it moving what do you give this
video one to ten it's garbage it's utter
[__] garbage I'm angry today
anyway don't watch Disney Disney can go
to hell yeah all right
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to like subscribe join my Discord
for a pre free preview of all my
business advice how I've generated over
500 million views onto my personal brand
and I'll see you later
[Music]